[Music]
[Applause]
what is your morning routine like what
do you do in your first get up in the
morning you know believe it or not I
still you know I need a physical paper
every single morning that's fine I read
The Wall Street Journal every morning I
read the New York Times online and you
know I still I'm very particular about
having my tea it's very English I'm
vegetarian so I need to get my protein
so I always have an omelet in the
morning with toast tea and read my paper
so I do that every morning times you
wake up 6:30 to 7:00
so that's when I do it do you exercise
in the morning no later in the day
sometimes you know if I get a chance but
always in the evening I wish I could do
it in the morning I'm not a morning
person so I need my time with my paper
and tea to wake up and kind of get going
you just watch - amazing clips with
sundar Pichai take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]